four months after a presidential
election
gambians once again came out to vote
many of them consider this parliamentary
election as important as the one that
returned president adam abarra to power
entire gambia
yeah we need change yeah because the
real gambey is going it's not promising
at all it's not promising so we need a
total change in the house of the
assembly
yeah
so that the constitution can be amended
yeah we need a new draft consultation
because the 1997 constitution is the
worst constitution ever
but the president said he considers the
election an important step our democracy
is moving
that means the field is level
and i think that is very good
going forward because it was a
transition period now the transition is
over we have consolidated ourselves we
have built a strong foundation moving
forward
the election commission says the channel
was much lower than in the presidential
vote in december
local observers say that may be because
a parliamentary vote came so soon after
the presidential race
analysts in the gambia suggest a low
voter turnout could give the governing
npp party only a small majority if that
happens the president then will have to
find new partners to push through his
agenda in parliament
although the president won a landslide
re-election four months ago analysts
predict he faces tougher times ahead
if he doesn't win the majority it will
be very difficult for him but of course
i think uh for me a national assembly
should be filled with different voices
and it is there this is the it should be
the business of politicians um to see
how they can work together to ensure
that what is of benefit to the nation is
is advanced
people in the gambia are now waiting to
find out who will be representing them
in parliament
election officials expect most of the
results to be announced on sunday
mohammed idris al jazeera abuja